We need your help
to fund the resistance.
Our pal Alex Jones knows exactly
what I'm talking about.
We need financial support.
You know, the globalists
are after us on every front,
and we make it easy to do
with really high quality.
The best water filters,
the best air filters,
the best T-shirts
to spread the word,
and ball caps.
Super male vitality, 50% off.
We've got the probiotic
bomb defense, 50% off.
Pour that in on a couple ice
cubes and, folks, it tastes--
when it's creamy and thick--
I think, better than Ovaltine.
And it is got all the
bone broth, and so much more.
This is why the ancients,
they believe, were... had such
better bones, were so much
healthier. You can look it up.
Yeah, yeah. Exactly.
Our ancestors were healthier.
I mean, not in terms
of life expectancy, but...
in terms of not living
long enough to get divorced.
Yes, healthier.
You free thinkers
have been sending Jones
your hard-earned cash--
at least $18 million a year--
but we also need your support
to defeat the globalists.
That's why, next week,
you have to ignore
all of the corporatist
Black Friday sales
and instead support
The Opposition
at our very first
All Lives Friday Sale.
(cheering, applause)
We'll have discounts on all
of our high-quality products.
And you can check out
the Web site right now
at ShOpposition.com.
People, you need this stuff
to survive.
Don't listen to the brainwashed
authorities who say that
our products are snake oil--
unless they're talking about our
medicated serpent balm,
which is, in fact,
mostly snake oil.
All Lives Friday will be packed
with serious deals
for serious threats.
Folks, you saw the elections.
You saw 'em last week.
Our country is drowning
under a blue wave of Democrats.
-(woman whoops)
-But...
Yeah, woo, you're scared too.
You can fight back
with Seeing Red,
our 100%
hydrochloric acid drops
that give your eyeballs
a red film
so the world looks just like
Trump's electoral map.
Quack doctors will say
this crimson filter
is just capillaries
exploding in your eyeballs.
I say it's the truth
exploding in your brain.
Also, we're going 50% off
on Liver Trainer,
the isopropyl alcohol formula
that challenges your liver
to step up
or shut the (bleep) down.
And we are nearly out of stock
on our amazing Pro-Guyotics,
filled with all-male
micro-organisms
to make your gut
health smarter, stronger,
and better at finding
restaurants on Yelp.
Ladies and gentlemen, you have
to go to ShOpposition.com.
Mothers, fathers, even kids.
It's never too early
to start opposing,
am I right, Laura?
Absolutely, Jordan.
Children are under attack
from progressive toys. Look.
REPORTER: Sally Ride and three
other women, all NASA pioneers,
are being honored
with their own likenesses.
The Women of NASA Lego set
went on sale this week,
and it quickly became
the top-selling toy on Amazon.
Did you see that, Jordan?
Female Legos are taking away
male Lego jobs
like pirate
and Han Solo.
What's next, genderless
toy people that don't even
have the best part
of a Lego-- the genitalia?
No, no. Screw all this
Danish gender bending.
We need to get back
to good, old-fashioned
American blocks: bricks.
(straining): Let me tell you,
Jordan, my kids love these.
They've built tons of
not-up-to-code structures
and still have so many fingers
they haven't broken yet.
KLEPPER: Oh, incredible,
that's incredible.
With ShOpposition.com products,
we can literally
rebuild our republic.
The All Lives Friday sale--
it's the only way to prepare
for what we all know
is coming later this year:
the apocalypse.
That's why I'm stocking up
on Oppo-calypse survival packs,
filled with
the essential products
that the best preppers demand:
non-GMO bandages,
a coal-powered hot plate,
miniature Confederate monuments,
pepperoni supplements,
decals that make sticks
look like laser guns,
And the complete collection
of Trump's tweets
that will become
the new Constitution
when society rises
from the ashes.
And, guess what,
this is special.
And if you order tonight,
I am throwing in
this exclusive private bathroom.
Which comes with
an additional guest bathroom.
(applause)
Guys, this...
Look at this!
This deal is crazy!
You have to buy now,
or you will perish later!
We don't know what's coming
for us, opposers.
Robots? Demons?
Citi Bikes? Who knows?
You need products to fight
the battle,
and the best way to fight
the liberals
is to trigger the (bleep) out
of 'em.
And Aaron and Josh
have just the thing.
Yes, we do, Jordan!
The kale males will freak out
when they see you wearing
our super sturdy,
25-thread-count
Texas cotton T-shirts,
with cuck-baiting phrases like
"God hates facts"
-and "Judas was a lib."
-Yeah.
At ShOpposition.com,
you can get a whole wardrobe
that says,
"I believe in free speech
more than I care
about being allowed back
into this grocery store."
Or we have a capelet
with the one phrase guaranteed
to make the kombucha chuggers
bleed from their ears
and shriek from their eyeballs,
-"Austin Powers 3 is
Beyoncé's best work." -Ooh.
-It's literally
a statement piece. -Yeah.
Hey, and just because
Jeff Sessions
won't go after Hillary
doesn't mean your ass can't.
KLEPPER:
Oh. Yes.
Yes. That ass won't quit,
and neither should
a special prosecutor.
Look, bottom line,
I'm not exaggerating:
your family, friends,
and country will crumble
into a pile of trash
if you don't support
the fight at ShOpposition.com.
And, in return,
we promise to keep fighting
until every one of your dollars
is gone.